today's message is be ready if you want
the big goals to happen if you want to
reach your dreams if you want to take
that next step with your company if
you're tired of being stuck in
mediocrity and doing all of this work
and not getting results need to be ready
for success you need to be ready for
that big state because when it comes
knocking chances are it's not because
you don't have the ready mindset so
here's an example when I go into making
my youtube videos what I try to do is I
imagine that it's not just a hundred
thousand people who are watching this
video on my channel it's reaching
millions it's going out to the biggest
network there is that the famous
entrepreneurs that I profile they're
gonna watch this and the fifty cents
case he did and in other people they're
gonna watch it too and it's that mindset
because it forces you to play a bigger
game if you're a musician and you're
playing at some dive bar and there's 10
people in the audience pretend like as
Madison Square Gardens because it makes
you play better it makes you think
bigger it makes you be the best version
of yourself and those are going to
create the opportunities to help you go
play that bigger game too many people
aren't ready too many people your stuff
it's just okay your product or service
is just okay you're not ready for the
big stage and so it comes from adopting
that mindset imagine like the stuff that
you're already making is already great
is going to be the best you can make it
and is reaching millions of people force
yourself to play that bigger game and I
tried to do that every time I'm creating
the video I'm going on a phone call I'm
doing a presentation it's not just for
that small group and I get that it can
be hard I get that it's hard because you
look at your current surroundings and
it's not great right there's only 10
people in the room you're working off of
a crappy youtube video camera you know
your product isn't fantastic yet you
gotta hustle to change that mindset to
force yourself to play that bigger game
and and just the awareness makes the
difference just me before radio show
going on thinking this is a nationally
syndicated radio show that all of my
mentors are going to be listening to
just me thinking that already ups the
stakes already makes my show way better
because it makes me way better so how
this relates to my
look that's what this video is all about
the book update I get a publisher call
yesterday or email saying they might
want to push back the date of my book I
supposed to have it in October 15th
they're asking if maybe we should move
the January citing a whole bunch of
reasons there's a lot of books coming
out in the fall there's the election you
know blah blah blah there's a lot of
books come out in January some
difference I don't know what the full
story is going to find that out but to
me does it matter I'll be ready you want
an October I'll be ready you want in
january i'll be ready and I'm taking the
mindset of this book is already a
best-seller I'm writing the best seller
that's what I'm going in thinking and so
it forces me to put the most that I have
into it and it forces me to write the
best that i can write that's what it's
all about and if I went in thinking ha
it's just a book whatever put my name on
it no big deal I don't put in that juice
in that effort then it won't be a
best-seller so I'm going in already with
the mindset that I'm ready whatever that
you want it i'll have it to you and it's
going to be a best-seller and so your
business be ready ok time to answer your
questions first stop Sam rock have you
considered where you're going to sell
the book just off your own website or
elsewhere so it's going to be it's not a
self-published book right I've got a
publisher will be in bookstores it'll be
online but it's going to be up to me to
do most of the hustling and I've got a
few things planned right now everything
that I'm doing is based on one writing
the book and helping you guys join in on
the process in terms of it coming out
it's typically a year after you submit
the book so I've got to submit it in
October or January now and then I'll
come out in the following fall or new
year I guess and that entire time I'm
going to be using to start building up
awareness and attention around marketing
this book and I think maybe potentially
in marketing other books as well the
easiest way to start getting attention
and awareness is to partner up and make
alliances with people who already have
your target audience so giving the book
the people who share my common interest
and have large entrepreneur audiences
going on their YouTube channels doing
Twitter chats with them writing blog
posts for them working with the
mainstream media as well but I think
something that I'm toying with is you
know what do we do with this series this
is a regular series that comes out once
a week you guys are asking
questions and tuning in and at the start
it's all been about me right in my book
and the process to hopefully kind of
give you guys a sneak peek behind the
scenes of what happens when you're right
in the published book but once the book
is done then what does it become and I'm
open to suggestions if you guys want to
leave a comment below my thinking is
I'll turn it into how am I going to then
market the book how am I preparing to
sell the book because writing the books
not enough you got to get it out into
the hands of people and so if you guys
are interested in that let me know and I
might just make that happen and if you
have other suggestions let me know that
too next up Dominic with a bunch of
questions first of what percentage of
the book is about you and your story
this is a great great question the book
is divided into three main sections and
I tell my story throughout the first two
sections are much more my story and i'm
sharing how I did things I share the
theory I share how I executed it and
then I share specific examples in the
last section of the book I share a
little bit about me and then more about
other companies to try to show that the
ideas that I'm presenting in the book
are applicable to a big range of
businesses so the last section is going
to be I have my business I have a
business that's making fifty thousand
dollars a year one is half a million one
that's over a million one that's five
million and one that's 200 million and
showing how they use the principles that
are in the book so that wherever you are
in the stage of your growth you'll be
able to relate to hopefully my story but
then also at least one or two of the
other stories so section one and two is
a lot of my examples and in section 3 is
a mix of mind and other examples have
you thought about the book cover style a
little bit most of it is is based right
now on getting the content done
and having the manuscript sent to the
publisher do you want to outsource the
design or will design it yourself I
don't know if I'll design it myself
probably not I like working with people
who are great at what they do right the
book is going to be great and I wouldn't
want to limit the cover to something
that I'm not great at I will definitely
have input into it I will talk with my
publisher and see what they typically do
in terms of book covers I'll tell you
i'm not going to release something that
I don't love I need to be inspired by it
and really feel in love with the cover
so I'm going to be hands-on but won't
likely be doing it myself because I
don't really have the skills to do it
how many pages with a book have and
thank you right now they asked me for
seventy thousand words so I don't know
how many pages that translates into and
I don't know what's going to get edited
and cut and if stuff gets cut out maybe
I'll give you guys free bonus sections
and chapters but around seventy thousand
words and then I guess you can look up
how many pages that is next stop Kyra
hey have a great video I learned so much
when you answer questions for other
people thank you glad you're liking it
I'm about to launch my first book for
children ages five to eight I just plan
on doing ads online but an opportunity
just came right can have a presence at a
book convention you think it is wise to
spend some money at the convention
instead of hush using ads it's a good
question i'm not sure that i would spend
my money on either you want to make sure
that your target audience is there so is
your target audience going to be at that
book convention maybe i'm a big believer
in starting small and testing before
expanding and so you might think it's
like a big opportunity but i'm really
trying to see if they've had you know
what do I try to talk to people who've
gone through it before as for other
authors who've been there did they get
results you know what are your goal is
your goal to get an agent is it to get
more distribution to get a media parents
to actually sell some books there
and I try to figure out if it's worth it
because for me I would probably not do
any conventions unless I was invited to
be a speaker there just because I don't
feel like the juice is worth the squeeze
the amount of time invested into
preparing getting the booth ready flying
there it's you know that takes a week of
time and preparation and actually
executing I could have spent that week
doing a lot more valuable things
probably now this is an exception is an
amazing convention that may be but I
would really need to get some quality
testimonials of people who say that it
was the difference for them in their
book otherwise I wouldn't do it for ads
I'd also be really worried you'll make a
lot of money off of each book so this is
a challenge and I would be really
targeted in who I'm going after so if I
was to use an ad product I would
probably go after facebook because you
can really get into people with your
dark posts and so for example if you're
looking at those children's books what
did you say ages five to eight look at
look up people who are who have kids you
can look at their interests and and run
ads against those interest but again I
would really look to see if that's
paying off you know I hate spending
money before I'm making money and I
would really be looking at metrics that
if I'm putting my ads out there am I
getting enough of return on it where I
would tend to skew and in my thinking
how i'm going to promote it much more
working with influencers much more you
know i would be looking at who are the
people who are reaching that audience
already and how can you be on their
youtube channel how can you be on their
talk show how can you get written up in
in the newspaper how can you get on CNN
how can you partner up with the people
who are celebrities on twitter and on
instagram i think you get much better
results but test you know that's my bias
test run those ads just make sure you
can track them don't just blindly assume
that they're working because you could
run out of money
in a hurry by the way I have a son who's
five years old so maybe we could do
something together let me know about
that book Lynn wrote in to say can you
share who your publisher is yet so i'm
working with perigee which is part of
penguin Random House I've talked about a
couple of times in the videos but i have
a literary agent Dupree Miller and they
set up a whole bunch of calls with
publishers back to back to back to back
and basically set up a bidding war and a
chance for us to connect and talk with
the different publishers and make sure
they got the vision of the book and
where the right people that work with
and so that's why I signed with toss
today rights to say I wonder if the book
is called I hate paperwork I went on a
bit of a rent last week about paperwork
but no the book is not called I hate
paperwork and last fernando i will buy
your book looking forward to it thanks
bro appreciate the love and support and
thank you guys every week for watching
and asking questions it's an amazing
journey to be on and i'm glad i can take
you guys with me so if you want to ask
me a question about this video about my
book about the book writing process
about your book leave it in comments
below and I will answer it for you next
week thank you guys for watching you
need to believe and I'll see you soon